it's the innocent people who who suffer
in this um Palestinian children bleed
too on the first day of Israel's bombing
um a family of 19 who' fled their home
because of a warning shot nearby to
another building were in the building
when it was hit by a missile 19 people
dead mostly women and children um
according to the AP reporter on the
scene didn't seem to be a military
Target there of course this is what
happens when Guerilla armies which is
what Hamas is retrea into the civilian
population of course this is what
happens in the builtup slums that
constitute most of Gaza City uh it may
not be um the aim of Israeli policy
although most in the Arab world will
certainly think that it is one of the
dispiriting things in the 24 or 48 hours
after the attack was looking at the Arab
press and seeing almost no coverage of
the Israeli victims people's hearts were
hardened right from the outset and
that's what I got in telephone calls
with people they feel they have their
victims that have always been ignored
and now they're ignoring the Jewish
victims makes you very pessimistic about
any outcome